i thank the representative of mexico
for her statement and i shall now make a
statement
in my capacity as the representative of
the russian federation
colleagues today we've had an intensive
day from the point of view of
discussions of the ukrainian crisis
i won't repeat what i said this morning
at the general assembly
i can only state with the regret that
taking stock of the day our signals to
kiev about the need to stop provocations
against lugansk and donetsk people's
republics were not heeded
it would appear that our ukrainian
colleagues who recently have been
actively armed and egged on by a host of
states
are still harboring the illusion that
with the beneviction benediction of
their western sponsors they will be able
to achieve a military solution to the
problem they're done
otherwise it is difficult to explain the
substantial intensification of shelling
and acts of diversion on the territory
of these republics
the special monitoring mission of the
oce recorded today almost 2 000 cases of
violations of the ceasefire regime
including almost one and a half thousand
explosions
those living in donetsk and london still
sheltering in basements
refugees are still flowing into russia
in a word the nature of the provocation
by the ukraine and military has not
changed
you don't want to notice this repeating
the ukrainian fairy tales that those
living in donetsk are all but shelling
themselves it is no surprise that the
increasing suffering of those living in
the dunbas does not seem to affect our
western colleagues
through the whole
day of debate today at the general
assembly you haven't been able to find
one word of compassion or condolences it
is as if these four million people for
you
simply don't exist
would like to recall that the principle
of sovereignty and territory and quality
of state
territory integrity of states in
violation of which
we are being accused of violating in
ukraine today according to declaration
the principles of international law
pertaining to friendly relations between
peoples adopted in 1970
they should be fully complied with as
regards states who and i quote
conduct themselves in compliance with
the principle of equal rights and
self-determination of peoples and thus
possessed of a government
representing
the hobby without distinction of race
creed or color the whole people living
in that territory end of quote
today's government in ukraine simply is
not that
and the tragedy in ukraine started
indeed after the illegal
coup in maidan in 2014.
when rather than dialogue with a
russian-speaking citizens of ukraine the
new authorities brandished guns and
airplanes at them
information and testimony to this end is
more than sufficient however our western
colleagues
prefer not to notice this
we tried yesterday and today
yesterday before yesterday to explain to
you the logic of the decision made by
russia to recognize the lpr and dpr and
we focused on the need to ensure peace
and security
there
you don't want didn't want to hear from
hear this and you don't want to hear it
now
for you those living in dunbas are
simply pawns in a geopolitical game
focused on weakening russia
and promoting the uh blocker from nato
to borders for us these people are women
children the elderly who for eight years
have been cowering from ukraine's
shelling and provocations for us these
are ukraine people
this is the difference in our approaches
if you do not change the geopolitical
lens you will never understand
those on whose behalf this decision i
mentioned was made
simply calling them pro-russian
separatists and terrorists
those people are the most important for
us i'd like to say once again the root
of today's crisis around ukraine is the
actions of ukraine itself who for many
years are sabotaging its obligations
under the mints package of measures
last week even there was a hope that
kiev would rethink
and nevertheless implement what it
signed up to do in 2015.
for this first and foremost they needed
direct dialogue with donetsk and legansk
however
further confirmation that ukraine is not
ready for this type of dialogue and
steps to grant donbass special status as
set forth in the minsk agreements
with the support of this position from
western backers
finally convinced us that we simply
cannot force those living in the donbass
to suffer more
and as much as i already said the
ukrainian provocation against those in
dunbas not only has not stopped but has
intensified
the leaders of the lpr on the dpr turn
to us with a request to provide military
support in line with bilateral
uh cooperation agreements as
agreed at the same time as they were
recognition this is a logical step which
is a consequence of the actions of the
ukrainian regime
during this meeting the president of
russia
putin
spoke
and said that he made a decision for a
special military operation in the
donbass
we don't know all the details today but
briefly i would like to inform you that
from his uh statement he says that the
occupation of ukraine
is not in our plans the aim
of the special operation is to protect
the people who for over eight years have
been suffering genesee genocide from the
kiev regime and for this we will
aim to demilitarize and
degenocide in ukraine and also
support those
and
hold accountable those who carried out
so many crimes against civilians
including this
including citizens of the russian
federation this decision was made in
line with article 51 of the un chapter
and the
a lot of information and we will analyze
this and we will keep you up to date
with this now i resume my function as
president of the council
and i give the floor to the
representative of ukraine
i'll distinguish members of the security
council
secretary general
under
secretary before i try to deliver parts
of the statement that i came here with
tonight
most of it is already useless
since
10 p.m new york time
i would like to cite
article 4
of the u.n charter
and it says
membership in the united nations is open
to all
other peace-loving states
which accept the obligations contained
in the present charter
and in the judgment of the organization
are able and willing
to carry out these obligations
russia is not able
to carry out any of the obligations
the ambassador of the russian federation
three minutes ago confirmed that his
president declared
a war on my country
so before i read parts of my statement
i would like to avail of the presence of
the secretary general and request the
secretary general
to distribute among the members of the
security council
and the members of the general assembly
the legal memos
by the legal counsel
of the united nations dated december
1991
and in particular the legal memo dated
19th of december 1991
the one that we've been trying to get
out of the secretariat for
a very long time and we were denied to
get it
the article 4 paragraph 2 of the charter
reads
the admission of any such state to
membership in the united nations will be
affected
by a decision of the general assembly
upon the recommendation of the security
council
mr secretary general please instruct the
secretariat
to distribute among the members of the
security council and the members to the
general assembly
a decision by the
security council dated december 1991
that recommends
that the russian federation
can be a member of this organization
as well as a decision by the general
assembly dated december 1991
where general assembly welcomes the
russian federation
to this organization
it would be a miracle if the secretariat
is able to produce
such decisions
there is nothing in the charter of the
united nations about continuity
as a sneaky way to get into the
organization
so when i was coming here
an hour ago so
i was intending to ask the russian
ambassador to confirm
on the record
that the russian troops will not start
firing
at ukrainians today
and go ahead with the offensive it
became useless
48 minutes ago
because about 48 minutes ago your
president declared the war on ukraine
so now i would like to ask the
ambassador of the russian federation to
say on the record
that at this very moment
your troops do not shell
and bomb
ukrainian cities
that your troops do not move in the
territory of ukraine
you have a smartphone you can call
lavrov right now
we can make a pose
to let you go out and call him
if you are not in a position
to give an affirmative answer
the russian federation ought to
relinquish responsibilities
of the president of the security council
pass these responsibilities onto a
legitimate member of security council
a member that is respectful of the
charter
and i ask the members of security
council
to convene an emergency meeting
immediately
and consider
all necessary draft decisions to stop
the war
because it's too late my dear colleagues
to speak about the escalation too late
the russian president declared the war
on the record should i play the video of
your president
ambassador shall i do that right now or
you can't confirm it
do not interrupt me please thank you
don't ask me questions when you are
speaking proceed with this proceed with
your state anyway you declare the war it
is a responsibility of this body to stop
the war
so i call on every one of you
to do everything possible to stop the
war
or i should i play the video with your
president declaring the wall
thank you very much
i must say that i
thank the representative of ukraine for
his statement and the questions
i wasn't planning to answer them because
i've already said all i know at this
point
waking up miss minister love rob at this
time is not something i plan to do you
said the information that we have will
be something we provide
and this isn't called a war this is
called a special military operation in
the donbass i now give the floor to the
representative of germany
mr president we meet at the very moment
of a military escalation we have not
experienced in europe for over a
generation's time
the president of the russian federation
announced a military operation on
ukrainian territory
we condemn this in the strongest
possible terms
and we call upon all members of the
security council and the united nations
to now stand up for ukraine
and again against a shameless breach of
international law
two days ago russia's decision to
recognize the self-proclaimed so-called
people's republics of
donetsk and luhansk was harshly rejected
in this council
it had already dealt a devastating blow
to the principles and the international
order that the united nations stand for
russia has not listened
and
it turns out it was not prepared to
listen
it has continued its massive military
buildup
and we observed and observed cyber
attacks directed against ukraine
and now russian military is moving into
ukrainian territory
by the actions and this unprovoked
military operation russia is violating
the core principles of the u.n charter
we condemn the use of force against in
an innocent people and the violation of
the sovereignty and territorial
integrity of ukraine in the strongest
possible terms
we urge russia to terminate its military
action against ukraine immediately
and withdraw its troops
mr president our thoughts are with the
ukrainian people we will be steadfast in
our support for ukraine and our support
for the u.n charter
the russian aggression will come at an
unprecedented price politically
economically and morally
mr president france ukraine and my
country stood ready for diplomacy for
another meeting in the normandy format
or for the summit that ukraine had
proposed
with our allies and partners
we called on russia to seek a diplomatic
way forward in vain
now is the moment to speak up and defend
the international order of the un
charter against unilateral aggression
jointly and decisively
tonight we stand with ukraine and we are
doing so unwavering and determined thank
you mr president
i thank the representative of germany
for her statement
and now i give the floor to the united
states who wish to
ask to make a further statement
thank you
in my remarks tonight i said that we
predicted
russia's false flag attacks
the misinformation
the theatrical emergency meetings and
the cyber attacks
but one piece had not come to pass
unfortunately
while we've been meeting in the security
council tonight
it appears that president putin has
ordered that last step
at the exact time
as we are gathered in the council
seeking peace
putin delivered a message of war in
total disdain
for the responsibility of this
this council
this is a grave emergency
the council will need to act
and we will put a resolution on the
table tomorrow
as president biden said tonight
russia alone is responsible for the
death and destruction this attack will
bring
and the united states and our allies and
partners will respond
in a united and decisive way
the world will hold russia
accountable
thank
i you the representative of the united
states
uh
for her statement i now like to give the
floor to the representative of the
united kingdom who asked to make a
further statement
oh thank you
as we sat in
[Music]
as we sat in this chamber urging russia
to step back
president putin announced special
military operations on ukrainian
territory
this is unprovoked and unjustified
this is a grave day for ukraine
and for the principles of the united
nations
we and our partners have been clear that
there will be consequences
for russia's actions
we fully support the united states call
for un security council resolution
this council must do all it can
to stop the war
and uphold the charter thank you
i thank the representative of the united
kingdom and now i'll give the floor to
the representative of albania who also
wish to make a further statement
dear colleagues we could not end this
meeting that what we had feared and
anticipated since days
is happening
explosions are reported in kievan in
several other cities in
ukraine
mosques are finally down and tanks are
in
as we speak
russia is implementing its plan
and attacking a neighbor to whom it has
decided to deny existence
freedom
the land
dignity and life
we call on all the members of the united
nations to rally in support of ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
to stand with ukraine and its people
to condemn firmly and unequivocally this
aggression
to stand for peace for rules for
international law and take whatever
measures they deem necessary to show the
aggressor that its actions will bear
consequences
let me reiterate
russia will be hold responsible for the
consequences of an unprovoked war
for the loss of human rights for causing
unbearable human pain and for opting for
destruction when we need development for
bringing death where we inspire for need
and for hope for choosing to become an
outlaw when we need cooperation
russia will bear historical blame and
shame and the consequences of invading a
neighboring country and attempting to
destroy european security
let's unite and make sure it will not
succeed
thank you
thank the representative of albania and
i now give the floor to the
representative of france for a further
statement
mr president mr president
at the time when we are in an emergency
meeting
to try to prevent the worst
and for more breaking out
we learned
we all learned that the president of the
russian federation had coordinated
a special military operation in donbass
and that
russia will do itself to demilitarize
ukraine
russia has therefore chosen war
france condemns in the strongest
possible terms
the initiation of these operations this
decision
announced at the very moment when the
council was
meeting
shows the disdain which that russia has
for international law and for the united
nations
russia must be accountable to the
security council
for this reason
france will join us partners in this
council and in the hours to come
we'll prepare a resolution condemning
the
war conducted by russia we call on all
members of this council to support us
under these tragic circumstances
we call on the russian federation to
respect
international humanitarian law no matter
what the circumstances we call for the
protection and respect of all civilians
including particularly
vulnerable persons women children and
humanitarian personnel thank you sir
and i give the floor
now to the representative of ireland to
make a further statement
thank you mr president
when i spoke earlier i said that the
path for diplomacy and the path for
dialogue was perilously narrow
and i didn't realize in fact how
narrow and indeed how close to the
precipice we really were
just over an hour ago
we now see that that path has been
closed by the announcement of
a military aggression on the part of the
russian federation against ukraine
that is something that we randomly
condemn
we stand with the people of ukraine
tonight with every man woman and child
who is seeing this news as we did as we
sat here in the chamber and whose lives
are at risk
we believe it is now time indeed for
this council
to
stand up and assume its responsibility
and to speak out in the strongest
possible terms about this
act of aggression thank you mr president
yeah
i thank representative ireland and i now
give the flaw to the representative of
ukraine to make a further statement
[Music]
well as i said
relinquish your duties as a chair
call putin call lavrov
to stop aggression
and i welcome the decision of
some members of this council
to meet as soon as possible to consider
the necessary decision
that would condemn the aggression
that you launch on my people
there is no purgatory for war criminals
they go straight to hell ambassador
i wanted to say in conclusion that we
aren't
being aggressive against the ukrainian
people but against the
junta that is in power in kiev there are
no more speakers on the list this
meeting is
adjourned right so uh you've been
watching live pictures there of an
extraordinary uh second emergency un
security council meeting in new york it
was called earlier uh by ukraine
following the separatist leaders in
ukraine calling for russian military
help